what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with
invincible yes we are we are continuing
the vulture might war and i guess i left
you guys on one heck of a cliffhanger
last week
uh but this basically picks up in the
aftermath of that right so mark just
in complete and total shambles conquest
is dead nolan and oliver are currently
on the planet and then of course you've
got tech jacket and you've got allen who
are just kind of out there doing their
thing so
by and large this kind of group of five
guys right this group of just
powerhouse characters is just really
kind of left in shambles and so the
result of this
is that when you end up having you know
end up transitioning to telescope which
again
is the home of the coalition of planets
this kind of ban something akin to like
the rebel alliance or what have you from
star wars who are basically working
together to try to take out the
the viltrumites that you have the news
that's given to
the head of the coalition of planets
right and he immediately freaks out now
the funny thing about this is
thaddeus again is a vulture mic so
that's one thing to bear in mind it's
something that almost nobody knows
and rightfully so right i mean how
likely would you be to follow a guy
who's leading a war against a race only
to find out he's a member of that race
that it would be
something of a huge amount of distrust
that's there because like well how do we
know he's actually working against the
vulture mites as opposed to for us
it's a very dangerous game that he's
playing here the other big thing about
this is that when he's given the news
that presumably or at least it's it's
perceived to be that nolan and oliver
and
invincible are dead albeit in reality
they're simply just missing an action
because there's no real way of knowing
what happened to them what their fate is
it terrifies the hell out of thaddeus
because the reality is they're the
linchpin right they're the linchpin to
the success of this thing
it's one thing to unite a whole bunch of
people against a particular cause
but if at the end of the day there's
there's not really much they have
in the way of arms and armament then it
would be like when the ethiopians were
fighting the germans during world war ii
right spears and arrows versus tanks
you're not really going to be able to do
much
and that was really what's going on here
without their heavy hitters they can
fight as best they can
but the vulture mites are nothing to
scoff at and one viltrumide is more than
enough
to handle a huge humanities forces let
alone
an entire army of viltrumites not to
mention anything of all the forces they
have conscripted to their service now
the reality of this
is tech jacket and alan are actually
stowing away the vulture might ship
right they're sewing aboard this ship
basically the way that han solo and then
stowed aboard a uh star destroyer right
you guys remember that from star wars
and literally tech jackets like i saw
this at a movie once
[Laughter]
so it works right it does this job but
you kind of switch over to uh to nolan
and to oliver basically dealing with
mark now one of the funny things about
this
is that uh you basically have nolan who
buries conquest
and the immediate response of oliver is
this is ridiculous right like you have
no idea the kind of things this guy's
done this guy does not deserve a funeral
but the reality of this
is that the lifetime of conquest
seems to have spanned thousands of years
and so the reality is that the things
that he's done
in the time that oliver has known him
basically tantamount to
a couple minutes within our lifespan
it's an exceedingly short amount of time
here not only that
nolan really kind of hits this idea that
when it comes to the vulture mites the
one thing that really seems to reign
supreme is duty and honor and so even
though conquest was by our standards
of villain in terms of how he operated
within the confines of the viltermite
empire he was a great warrior and so
it's one of these things where nolan
kind of looks at that and says even if
he did some shady stuff he still
deserves a warrior's funeral because he
was a great and honorable fighter
even if only insofar as how he operated
within the confines of the vulture might
empire now this is huge
because it's not nolan defecting back to
the villager mites and saying yeah i
mean i've
kind of i've seen the light and the
vulture might the way to go and then
kills oliver and then kills mark and
leaves right that's not really what
we're talking about here we're talking
about one of these things where despite
the fact that nolan has
has basically turned against the vulture
mind empire there are such things as
duty and honor that are universal that
are universally recognized as being
great things regardless of what side
you're fighting on and so it's also kind
of this concept it's not really given to
us it's not really stated specifically
but conquest was raised within the
ideologies of the vilture might empire
imagine what he would have been capable
of if he had turned in the same capacity
nolan had or if he had been raised by a
different race but still had the same
powers
and had a different set of values right
good and evil right and wrong
is all really relative those concepts
simply exist in relation to how we
function as an organized society
but you end up having them kind of
switching over really traveling back to
mark to keep an eye on him and of course
they don't really leave him they just
kind of stay with him but it's going to
be a long and arduous process because
what nolan says is that mark's going to
take months to recover now again
viltromites can heal but because mark is
such a young viltromite presumably with
hundreds if not thousands of years ahead
of him
assuming the human side of his
physiology doesn't kick in and basically
cause like a rapid aging process
relative to the age of viltromites
then this is basically him as a baby
recovering from an injury whereas
somebody like conquest recovered much
much faster because he's much much older
right now you would think as time goes
on the healing factor would kind of drop
off but at the end of the day it's one
of these things where it kind of seems
to be the middle ground right that you
know as
in given conquest age he was kind of in
the prime of his life so to speak so his
healing factor was kind of at its peak
we can sort of argue that kind of
present that scenario but regardless of
course it's one of these things where
nolan also looks at this situation
where it's basically a chance for him to
get to know his son
oliver better and so from there you
basically switch over to a scout ship
right
that's part of the coalition of planets
that kind of stumbles across that
previous battle that we saw between
battle beasts and a couple other forces
only to find
that battle beast has actually survived
the experience right he's frozen in
space
but he's basically survived the other
part of this is you have thaddeus who
meets up with these aliens now i've kind
of left these guys out just because of
the fact that you know i feel i felt
like it was a little
too much to throw in there in the
previous videos but these guys are kind
of like the intelligence hub right the
nervous system more or less of the
coalition of planets
essentially the ability for the
coalition to unify
and to operate on multiple fronts goes
through these guys
right like they they have almost
complete and total knowledge of the
operational procedures of the coalition
of planets
they become very important here and the
reason why is because the information
they give
is that at the end of the day they don't
know exactly where it is that nolan
and and all these guys are at allen
alien tech jacket uh mark oliver they
don't have any information on where
those guys are but what they do know
is that the vulture mites have basically
like they really initiated the first
strike the vulture mites are responding
and the war has already begun and so the
response of thaddeus is okay fine like
if what you guys are waiting for is to
to give the final word to basically
initiate the initial assault then i give
it right and so officially the coalition
of planets has now struck against the
viltrumide empire and the war just kind
of continues on the reality is it
already started but this is really kind
of like the full-scale
conflict taking place right so initially
with mark and all them we were talking
about like the invasion of poland right
now we're talking about england and
france declaring war against germany
that's where we're at now right like
we're really like okay like the meat and
potatoes of this have really started
and there is no going back here and so
what you get are these really
interesting juxtapositions between
oliver and nolan
and the coalition of planets right that
oliver and nolan don't know the whole
conflict is really
grown to the size that it has where the
coalition of planets has officially
launched its strike against vulture
might and the two
factions are now in a full-blown war
they don't know that right like they're
totally unaware of that and in reality
they probably don't care not because the
war effort's unimportant but because
tending to mark is more important and so
it's kind of this this funny thing
because it's only been a couple of weeks
and you end up having like this weird
looking alien thing that's killed by
nolan
and and oliver's you know he's like you
know it's aren't you like starving and
oliver's like no like i mean i am but
i'm not hungry enough to eat that thing
and nolan's like
okay we'll see what's up and then like
you immediately switch to oliver just
crushing this right like parental
knowledge right like kids being proud or
kids being foolish and it's like okay
i mean i've been where you are before
that's not gonna happen right like
you're starving and i promise you're
probably going to eat this and he does
and then he asks for seconds right he's
like is there any more
now the other part of this is that alan
the alien basically has a kind of
tracking device that emits a high
frequency signal that's planted inside
of his body
that can only really be detected or
seems to only be detected by the
coalition
of planets most likely because the
viltrumites don't know it's there so
they don't know the frequency to hijack
in order to
basically deactivate it interrupt it
basically make it look like he's
somewhere that he's not but because of
the fact that the coalition can track it
down
you basically have the coalition of
worlds that responds with a kind of
battalion of sorts that comes descending
onto this wheelchair might ship for the
purpose of rescuing
alan the alien and tech jacket right so
they get these guys they basically start
bringing them back
and then you kind of switch back over to
oliver and nolan right now this is a
really really cool moment here
because you have this situation where
oliver asks him the question he's like
you know the like he's like my mom
not my real mom right the the you know
insect looking mom but like my actual
earth mom right debbie you know like do
you really think you were in love with
her and it's a really interesting
question that this is asked because one
of the great things about oliver is he's
not
experienced in the same way that mark is
right he still very much sees the world
through the eyes of a child
and from the mouth of babes comes truth
and that's really one of the things
where he's just kind of
asking these questions because for him
they're legitimately curious and
interesting questions and the response
of nolan is i know i do
and it's this really interesting
scenario where he presents this kind of
discussion to her and talks about how he
was healing in the villager my prison
you know in order and it basically made
him realize yes he really does care
about debbie and it's kind of funny
because he says that like the
viltromites themselves they do have
affection
but they don't care for each other in
the same way that humans do right he
says our lives are so long
that over time we grow distant it's hard
to form a bond with someone
over that much time and he says you'll
never find one of us who will admit it
but we live very
lonely solitary lies especially with our
numbers so depleted living on earth
changed me seeing humans grow so close
to each other caring so deeply for their
loved ones
in the short amount of time allotted for
him it was special something to be
admired now that's a very
important thing to understand when it
comes to the vulture might so the reason
why is because
it's a true statement that that you know
nolan makes here they live such long
lives
but more so than that they're so
frequently separated from each other
unless you're talking about some
situation where they come together to
face off against some cause
or you need like three or four who are
going to defeat some enemy or something
like that
by and large the vulture might empire
does not really operate
in giant numbers right because they
don't have big numbers they're like
there's less than 100 of them left right
so you basically have them traveling
from world to world for the purpose of
conquering it and it might be one of
these things where they kind of hang out
but the reality is
any real relationship between one
villager mine and another is more or
less like two ships passing in the night
more so than that with this
kind of being the life of nolan for
thousands of years
the sudden change of arriving on earth
and the sudden change of being there and
kind of monitoring this place and then
having to kind of
sneak in and live a quote unquote human
life essentially introduced him
to aspects of what it meant to live that
he'd never really experienced before
experiencing all those things completely
and totally changed him because what it
did is it introduced the idea that there
is such a thing as caring about
something more than you care about
yourself
and that's really what he says he says
like i never looked at life as a chore
he says over time
i fell into the role of human husband
human father so much so that when mark
got his powers
it was a great burden more than anything
he said i had to go back
to being a vulture mind i had to do what
i was put there to do whether i wanted
to or not i spent a lot of time alone
then considering if i could ignore my
duty continue
living the lie i'd enjoyed so much with
the woman i'd grown to love
he just wanted to kind of enjoy his life
and that's why you
never really saw nolan doing things like
destroying the guardians of the globe
at a much earlier point in time because
in reality the life that he was living
was the life that he wanted
because it was new and it was fresh but
more so than that it was meaningful and
then suddenly mark comes along mark has
powers and it's like okay so now i have
to
like he was basically reminded of what
he was supposed to do and then he went
back to being a viltromite but didn't
want to
right he didn't want to but at the end
of the day the idea was if he doesn't
conquer the world the villager might
empire will come there and they will
take it right one way or another the
earth is going to be conquered but then
suddenly when he's separated from it all
and he realizes how much he loved his
wife
he realizes how much his son meant to
him then basically it turns into then
who cares about the vulture my empire
right like i will take that risk i will
turn against them and we will do the
best we can
and so again kind of getting this sort
of juxtaposition this back and forth
you have this really cool thing where
you have oliver talking with nolan the
two of them conversing the two of them
sort of learning more about each other
but even this realization that's given
to oliver be on behalf of nolan
which is that the truth is that a a kind
of merger between a vulture might in
different races
can actually produce a more powerful
offspring than simply just
vulture mites by themselves right that
hybrid physiology can potentially create
an incredibly powerful offspring now the
reality of this is
mark is really the more powerful out of
them right because mark is a blend
between
a human and a villager mine and as we
were previously told the
compatibility between vulture mites and
humans is big right so much so that it's
almost
perfect and so kind of these two these
two guys talking back and forth and
really kind of enjoying this sort of
simplicity of this life that they have
even if it's only minor right just
basically eating living
talking making sure march protected is
an extreme juxtaposition to allen the
alien
and the coalition of planets fighting
these villager mites fleeing for their
lives
fighting again over and over and over
again right peace versus war that's
really what you're seeing here and it's
kind of interesting
to see this thing because you also have
nolan who's basically giving all of her
fighting lessons
who's teaching him you know the level of
strength that he truly has how powerful
he can become
helping him grow that strength and a lot
of ways doing the things that he didn't
quite do for mark
and that's the nature of what it means
to be a parent it's not as though nolan
hated mark it's not as though he
despised him it's simply just that
as a parent when you have your first kid
you're gonna screw up consistently it's
only when you get your second kid that
you basically correct the mistakes you
made with your first kid but then you
end up making whole new mistakes
and so there really is no such thing as
a parent
as a time that comes when you simply
have a child and you make no mistakes
and you
raise them perfectly but for nolan he's
basically making up for a lot of the a
lot of the things he didn't do with mark
and he's basically doing that with
oliver which is cool because he's kind
of continuing to learn
and to kind of experience this whole
thing and so again cheering his son on
rooting his son on it's also kind of
switching over to thaddeus and this
revelation that one
battle beast has agreed to join the
ranks right so battle beast is fighting
alongside the ranks of the coalition of
planets which is awesome because this
guy's powerful enough to take out
viltromites the other part of this
is that for some reason they can't quite
seem to gain a foothold in the way that
they want to that while the viltrumites
aren't necessarily able to counter
every single move they make it seems
like the vulture might have an inside
man
and we've known about that for quite
some time that even thaddeus himself
said
there's a spy in the coalition of worlds
that's feeding information to the
vulture might empire we don't know who
this person is we don't know why they're
doing it but basically it seems as
though the viltrumites always know
what's going on and that's why they
should be gaining a much stronger
foothold
in this war than they are it's three
steps forward and two steps back
sure it's a one-step net gain but at the
end of the day from thaddeus's
perspective
it should be two or three right they
should be making far more advances in a
much bigger stride in this war than
there currently are
so the ultimate or the only real thing
for him to do is because of the fact
that they're missing nolan and they're
missing invincible and they're missing
oliver right the only real thing they
can do because they're missing these
heavy hitters is to basically split up
tech jacket
and allen alien because while they are
able to work effectively together they
might be equally effective but even
possibly even more effective by being
separated and so because of that is you
kind of switch over to mark and mark
just kind of waking up and ultimately
nolan's like okay cool it won't be long
now we have about another month or so
before all this starts to you know
before mark basically fully recovers so
again we're talking about like two or
three months before you know between the
time that mark was like severely injured
to the point that mark starts to wake up
and mark can basically recover
and get back into the conflict again now
under any normal circumstance there are
advanced ways of healing a person right
there's advanced ways of pulling that
off
the problem is mark's in a highly
vulnerable state so one they can't fly
to the coalition of worlds because it's
simply too far away
and two even if they could the
likelihood of them being attacked by the
viltrumites along the way
is very very high and so because of that
that's why their best bet was to simply
stay put so
in truth the recovery time of mark could
have been cut down to a couple weeks or
possibly even
days given the nature of the
circumstance that they're in they got to
let him recover
naturally now the funny thing is that
there's another reason why nolan's doing
this right why he's having mark recover
the hard way
as opposed to the easy way and we'll
find out what that is later on down the
line but what you end up doing here is
switching over to the home world of the
vulture mites too of course as you guys
call them freddie mercury
guys love calling the leader of the
villager might freddie mercury you guys
are
so sure that's the name of this guy and
honestly we just need to go with it
right like freddie mercury i can
guarantee when this when this guy's
revealed in the show they're gonna call
him freddie mercury right they're gonna
be like yeah man thrag
is definitely freddie mercury like it's
gonna be freddie mercury memes all over
the place
and i am so looking forward to it but we
end up finding out that the information
that's being fed to the vulture might
empire
is actually coming from one of the
aliens that's basically part of the
coalitional planet's nervous system
right the entire unification the entire
organized military front
passes through them and so because of
that they're in the best position
to pass information to thrack this is
what's basically crippling the war
effort of the coalition of planets this
guy's just dumping information all the
time and so what ends up happening is we
basically have this this kind of
back and forth between these guys and
thrad goes as far as to say you've been
feeding us information for years
but it's not enough we're still losing
planets to the coalition this is
unacceptable we will strike the
coalition headquarters on telestria you
will shut down their defenses at the
time being
at the time that's being transmitted to
you respond and the answer to this guy
is
it will be done right and that's when
the other guy's like what are you
talking about he's like yeah we're
basically going to set the stage for
the for the vulture mites to conquer the
coalition of planets with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace